c'est l'heure de notre second débat
évidemment autour d'une date le 5
octobre
1972 il y a 50 ans Jean-Marie Le Pen
créer le Front national depuis c'est un
clan familial qui domine l'extrême
droite et qui se rapproche petit à petit
du pouvoir Cécile Sioux
rassemblez les différentes chapelles
d'extrême droite c'est l'objectif de
Jean-Marie Le Pen quand il crée en 1972
le Front national mais les premiers pas
du mouvement politique se font dans
l'indifférence général et ses
composantes n'arrivent pas à s'entendre
selon le politologue Pascal Perrineau
spécialiste de l'extrême droite pour
mettre d'accord toutes les sensibilités
du Front national entre elles et ça
n'est pas rien parce qu'on ne peut pas
parler au fond d'extrême droite ce sont
des extrêmes droites et très vite il va
y avoir des scission dans ce tout petit
appareil c'est quelque centaines de
militants à l'époque et puis alors que
la machine avait été créée pour être une
puissance électorale une machine élect
ça ne marche pas Jean-Marie Le Pen se
présente à l'élection présidentielle en
1974 et obtient 0,7% des suffrages le
tournant s'opère dans les années 80 le
FN obtient ses premiers succès
électoraux en 1984 il gagne 10 sièges au
Parlement européen et en 1986 il fait
entrer 35 députés à l'Assemblée
nationale au fond tout le monde se dit à
l'époque c'est une poussée de fièvre les
Français 3 ans après la victoire de la
gauche sont un peu exospérés certains ne
sont pas contents du tout ils se sont
radicalisés à droite mais personne ne
prend ça vraiment au sérieux la grande
nouveauté c'est que la fièvre va
s'installer la fièvre s'installe le
mouvement gagne du terrain et montre
même sa capacité à dépasser les
turbulences internes fin 1998 La guerre
est déclarée au sein du parti entre le
pénis et mégrettiste le FN se divise
mais Jean-Marie Le Pen maintient le cap
et se place à peine trois ans plus tard
à la surprise générale au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle pour une
nouvelle niche et qui était alors son
directeur de campagne se rappelle le
soir des résultats le soir du premier
tour moi j'étais sur les plateaux on
commence à voir la mine embarrassée d'un
certain nombre de commentateurs ou de
représentants les autres formations
politiques et on réalise tu ressenti une
grande joie une excitation profonde et
aussi beaucoup d'angoisse parce
qu'évidemment je immédiatement ont
commencé des manifestations
attisés par les uns par les autres et ça
a été absolument incroyable en 2010
Jean-Marie Le Pen décide de transmettre
le témoin au congrès de Tours et sa
fille Marine Le Pen qui est choisie par
les militants contre Bruno Gollnisch qui
garde le souvenir d'une compétition
inégale moi je considère que quand on
participe à une compétition on en
accepte le résultat et j'avais trop
souffert de
la scission de 1998 pour provoquer je ne
sais quelle trouble trouble interne ou
pour contester les résultats en question
je les ai donc très loyalement accepté
Marine Le Pen veut transformer le Front
national en partie de pouvoir une
entreprise capuche suivre valerand de
Saint-Just cadre du parti
elle nous dit et elle a raison quand
vous êtes responsable de politique à
quelques niveaux que ce soit vous avez
qu'une seule chose à faire j'ai essayé
de détecter le mieux possible les
souffrances et les épreuves actuelles de
vos contemporains et c'est là vraiment
la directive qu'elle nous a donné
pendant tout le temps de sa présidence
et encore maintenant et c'est comme cela
que sous sa présidence le mouvement
c'est quand même bien détaché de
pesanteur qui qui subissait et que les
Français ont constaté mais qu'on se on
se professionnalisait encore plus ce
professionnaliser est devenu respectable
les dérapages du père ne sont plus
acceptés Jean-Marie Le Pen qui qualifie
de nouveau les chambres à gaz de détails
de l'histoire est exclu en 2015 j'étais
mort de la de la commission des conflits
qui a
exclu Jean-Marie Le Pen donc j'ai vécu
très frais j'ai vécu de façon très
douloureuse mais je vous ai dit que moi
j'étais un partisan du parti
et et il va sembler que c'était
l'intérêt du parti que d'exclure
Jean-Marie Le Pen d'aller jusque là
voilà d'exclure son fondateur pour
l'intérêt du parti c'est très difficile
humainement parlant des diabolisé
normalisées le FN devient le RN et
accède au second tour des élections
présidentielles de 2017 et de 2022 il
fait surtout entrer au Palais Bourbon 89
députés
et pour analyser la trajectoire du Front
national depuis 50 ans j'accueille
naudam Mayer bonjour bienvenue vous êtes
chercheuse et mérite au centre des
titres européennes à Sciences Po et au
CNRS martial Foucault directeur du
ceipov bonsoir et bienvenue à belmestre
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
politique quotidien Le Monde est
spécialiste des radicalités Laetitia
cruppa éditoris politique est resté
évidemment à mes côtés
moi j'avais titré un anniversaire en
barrassant est-ce que c'est forcément le
même ailleurs un anniversaire
embarrassant pour le rassemblement
national d'aujourd'hui et donc pour
Marine Le Pen
embarrassant je n'utiliserai pas ce
terme je pense que c'est un anniversaire
important
embarrassant si le père avait été là
peut-être le fait qu'il ne soit pas
invité au colloques certainement dû le
vexer mais montre encore une fois que
Marine Le Pen veut couper les liens avec
un passé qui ne passe pas de même
qu'elle a fermement à chaque fois
condamné l'antisémitisme à la différence
de son père qui se délectent pour
reprendre à chaque fois les chambres à
gaz point de détails de l'histoire de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale donc là c'était
pas tellement embarrassant c'est pour
eux c'est 50 ans c'est montrer qu'ils
ont changé peut-être dans la discussion
on verra qu'ils ont changé mais pas tant
que ça et que ils sont pas encore tout à
fait aux portes du pouvoir
Marcel Foucault que représente la figure
de Jean-Marie Le Pen pour les les
militants ou peut-être pas faisant les
jeunes mais les militants d'aujourd'hui
je crois qu'il faut regarder l'âge des
militants parce que en fonction de l'âge
évidemment la figure tutélaire
fondatrice du rassemblement national
aujourd'hui à probablement peu de peu
d'impact pour les plus anciens et je
crois que les témoignages qu'on vient de
d'entendre son importance c'est à dire
ceux qui ont accompagné Jean-Marie Le
Pen de la Fondation 1972 jusqu'à 2002
cette réussite au second tour de au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle
pour ces militants le succès la
trajectoire du Front national elle est
uniquement due à Jean-Marie Le Pen et
finalement on lui accorde beaucoup de
beaucoup de grâce malgré ces
débordements les polémiques et les
condamnations finalement on lui fait on
lui fait crédit que la fin justifie les
moyens justifient la fin en quelque
sorte pour les militants aujourd'hui
sous la présidence de Marine Le Pen je
je continue à penser que beaucoup
d'entre eux
pas forcément attaché à la figure de
Jean-Marie Le Pen et d'ailleurs même je
crois que d'une certaine manière vous
employez le terme est-ce que c'est un
anniversaire qui est important comme
disait Nola mayor à l'instant je pense
que Jean-Marie Le Pen est même
embarrassant pour beaucoup de ces jeunes
cadres du rassemblement national parce
que ce qui a été dit l'accès au pouvoir
du rassemblement national aujourd'hui ne
correspondrait certainement pas à ce que
Jean-Marie Le Pen aurait souhaité en
termes de comportement d'attitude de
prise de parole dans le débat public on
voit qu'on essaye d'arrondir de lisser
les choses gagner en respectabilité en
responsabilité ça je crois que c'était
pas dans dans l'étos de Jean-Marie Le
Pen abelmetz vous avez suivi pour le
monde les dernières années de Jean-Marie
Le Pen à la tête du Front national
l'avènement de de sa fille c'est quand
même il faut quand même dire ça dès le
début de ce débat c'est quand même aussi
l'histoire d'un clan familial dont on
parle il faut avoir ça en tête quoi oui
il y a une il y a un côté dynastique
chez les Le Pen et
un nom de famille indissociablement lié
à leur formation politique après le
congrès de cette année va voir pour la
première fois depuis 50 ans un nom Le
Pen en tout cas sans patronyme accéder à
la tête du parti soit Louis à Lyon mais
plus probablement Jordan Bardella et
évidemment on reste quand même dans le
giron familial on reste dans le petit
cercle autour de la famille
et ça reste des fidèles et aucun des
deux n'entend rompre la ligne impulsée
par Marine Le Pen qui elle-même c'était
inscrite dans les pas de son père quand
même lors de son discours en 2011 lors
de sa victoire au Congrès elle a rendu
hommage à son père et même encore
aujourd'hui
même s'il y a une rupture politique il y
a pas une rupture totale on le voit
d'ailleurs dans les intervenants du
colloque qu'elle organise il y a Bruno
goniche il y a quelqu'un qui s'appelle
Gilles Pennel qui est pas connu du grand
public mais qui est plutôt un radical
donc voilà elle envoie quand même encore
des signaux à cette à cette frange de
son parti de son électorat est-ce que le
père a encore une quelconque influence
sur la fille politiquement je parle
politiquement je crois que non je crois
que politiquement il y a vraiment eu
quelque chose de cassé sur le plan
familial ils se sont un tout petit peu
rabibéchés il me semble mais
politiquement là où Marine Le Pen a été
extraordinairement ferme même si tout le
parti ne suit pas c'est sûr
l'antisémitisme avec l'idée qu'il y a
une ligne rouge et elle s'était
brouillée déjà avec son père plusieurs
fois elle avait boudé le bureau pendant
des mois quand il avait pour la énième
fois repris son ancienne sur les
chambres à gaz donc je pense que quelque
chose s'est cassé là et puis au fond de
lui-même est-ce qu'il pourra lui
pardonner un jour de l'avoir exclu de
partie qu'il a co-fondé c'est difficile
même si en surface ils ont repris des
relations familiales mais quand on
écoute les discours de Marine Le Pen
alors c'est vrai que c'était pas
vraiment c'est grand meeting mais
certains discours et qui s'adressaient
aux militants elle reconnaissait la
filiation
j'ai de retrouver une archive qui date
de novembre 2021 donc c'était juste
avant la présidentielle elle était déjà
lancée dans la séquence présidentielle
et elle parle de ses 50 ans elle en est
fière elle est devant ses troupes et
elle dit bon bah on a quand même 50 ans
on va aller fêter et puis il y en a un
qui était là-bas en 72 j'étais là ah bah
très bien monsieur vous avez vu le
combat qu'on a mené maintenant nous
sommes au port du pouvoir donc vous
voyez qu'il y a un double discours il y
a un discours de notabilisation
officielle mais c'est vrai qu'avec les
troupes et en coulisses elle est quand
même assez fière du parcours du parti
parce qu'il faut pas non plus qu'elle se
coupe de la base historique de du Front
national c'est aussi cette logique là
est-ce qu'on peut dire ça oui mais je
pense que la l'avenir du rassemblement
national va dépendre de sa capacité à
attirer les électeurs fidèles donc je
dirais ce en âge de voter mais aussi de
nouveaux électeurs et ça je crois que
c'est un enjeu qui pourrait répondre à
votre question d'une rupture politique
mais la meilleure raison sur
l'antisémitisme probablement et c'est un
élément de césure entre Jean-Marie Le
Pen et Marine Le Pen mais je dirais
qu'elle a aussi organisée une rupture
idéologique sur d'autres domaines moi
j'ai des souvenirs de Jean-Marie Le Pen
défendant par exemple les accords du Gap
qui étaient pas encore l'OMC c'était un
libéral convaincu et même s'il y avait
des contradictions à la fois premiers
Américains mais très libre échangiste
les questions on l'évoque sur les
questions sociétales et culturelles sont
homophobie qui était très très fortes et
ça Marine Le Pen a vraiment pris un
virage à 180 degrés et sur le plan et ça
on l'a vu lors de l'élection sa première
élection présidentielle 2012 et
probablement avec autour d'elle de
nouveaux cadres et on pense évidemment à
Philippot par exemple dire voilà il faut
prendre le virage social il faut arrêter
de casser l'état il faut essayer de
montrer qu'il y a pas simplement une
clientèle de petits chefs d'entreprise
commerçants artisans et nona connaît
très bien ça dans ces travaux
qui était la clientèle électorale
presque de de base au début de ce parti
on a vu qu'il y a une très grande
ouverture sur d'autres segments de la
population alors je sais pas si Steve
Jourdain est là il est juste à côté de
nous donc on va l'accueillir sur ce
plateau parce que justement si vous vous
revenez à cette à cette date donc il y a
11 ans à l'occasion du passage de
flambeau entre Jean-Marie Le Pen et sa
fille on parle déjà il y a déjà ce mot
de dédiabolisation d'une certaine façon
petit flashback autour donc au congrès
de Tours en janvier 2011 Jean-Marie Le
Pen tire sa révérence et sa fille Marine
Le Pen qui prend les commandes du parti
mission affichée mission revendiquait le
des diabolisé le rendrait spectacle pour
en faire une alternative aux yeux des
électeurs mais alors que faire de
l'histoire du Front national de la
mémoire de ses fondateurs poujadistes
membres de la milice ou même ancien va
fait NSS après sa victoire à la
présidence du parti Marine Le Pen dit
tout assumer écouter là
c'est une nouvelle étape dans l'histoire
du Front national Jean-Marie Le Pen
président d'honneur du Front national
qui a été son président fondateur durant
40 ans il a donné la mission d'accéder
au pouvoir pour appliquer nos idées de
redressement de notre beau pays c'est
exactement ça quoi que nous allons nous
atteler dès demain matin comme pour
l'histoire de mon pays je prends
l'ensemble de l'histoire de mon parti et
j'assume tout
j'assume tout et pourtant c'est le début
de ce processus de des diabolisation la
dédiabolisation c'est un mot qui était
déjà utilisé par l'extrême droite dans
les années 60 et 70 mais Marine Le Pen
va aller plus loin elle en fait presque
un cri de ralliement elle sort un livre
en 2012 intitulé pour que vive la France
elle dénonce qu'elle appelle l'économie
du diable selon elle les profiteurs de
cette économie seraient les élites à
patrides les cosmopolites les puissances
de l'argent ou encore le capitalisme
transnational ce qui est intéressant
c'est que dans cette entreprise de
dédiabolisation marine va changer une
partie du logiciel idéologique du Front
national on va passer d'un parti
libérale on va ultralibéral sur le plan
économique à un parti protectionniste
qui mise sur l'état pour mettre un peu
d'ordre dans l'économie celui qui va
incarner cette nouvelle ligne c'est
évidemment les narcs Florian Philippot
il prône une ligne ni droite ni gauche
et se revendique du souverainisme de
Jean-Pierre Chevènement en 2014 pour ses
veulent après se Marine Le Pen s'attaque
à la mondialisation écoutez là
en 2014 nous incarnerons plus que jamais
la vraie vie face à nos adversaires qui
incarneront encore très probablement le
virtuel
nous reviendrons à la réalité celle que
vivent les Français nous reviendrons sur
le chômage le pouvoir d'achat la
mondialisation la sécurité l'immigration
le communautarisme les petits retraites
et nous laisserons les débats virtuels à
ceux qui fuient la vraie vie la vraie
vie la question du pouvoir d'achat c'est
un thème qui va s'imposer définitivement
au cœur de la stratégie Le Pen et pour
continuer la dédiabolisation en 2018
elle décide de changer le nom du parti
appelez-le désormais rassemblement
national le non rassemblement national
que je vous ai proposé ne correspond pas
seulement à la stratégie du mouvement
national qui est aujourd'hui de s'ouvrir
d'accueillir en son sein et à ses côtés
de nouveaux talents
aussi comme un cri de ralliement de tous
ces Français qui ne veulent pas se
résigner au goutte-à-goutte du déclin
bilan de l'air Marine Le Pen quelques
départs de figures de parties comme
Florent Philippot après l'échec de 2017
mais aussi des défaites qui peuvent
ressembler pour certaines à des
victoires on est passé d'un parti qui
faisait 17 % au second tour de la
présidentielle en 2002 à un parti qui
pèse aujourd'hui plus de 40% de ceux qui
votent restent à savoir ce qui est dû à
la dédiabolisation et ce qui est dû à un
contexte politique plus général Thomas
merci Steve abelmetz qu'est-ce qu'il y a
de commun si on regarde un peu le
programme
les idées les réformes proposées
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de commun entre le
rassemblement national d'aujourd'hui et
le Front national que Jean-Marie Le Pen
amène au second tour de la
présidentielle en 2002 en fait Marine Le
Pen ça disait des diabolisations c'est
une dialectique c'est une rupture sur la
forme et une permanence sur le fond et
sur le fond elle garde quand même la
pierre angulaire du programme du Front
national qui est la préférence nationale
enfin rebaptisé priorité nationale mais
c'est exactement le même concept qui est
quelque chose qui a été apporté c'est un
don des migressistes au corpus
idéologique du Front national mais elle
l'a gardé c'est à dire c'est réservé les
aides les logements pour pour les
Français et à partir de là tout coule en
fait tout c'est là structure principale
de ces mesures et ça elle l'a gardé il a
il est hors de question pour elle de
revenir sur ça et d'ailleurs dans les 50
ans si elle est vraiment voulu opérer
une rupture elle aurait fait un droit
d'inventaire un retour critique sur le
passé de de son parti elle n'en est pas
question ça va être la célébration des
apports dans le débat national du
programme du Front donc en fait vraiment
il faut bien mesurer qu'elle a établi
d'autres priorités que celle de son père
mais qu'elle garde l'essentiel du
programme et c'est pour ça que plusieurs
observateurs et dont beaucoup de
journalistes vont moi on continue de la
qualifier de partie d'extrême droite ou
de leader d'extrême droite c'est parce
que l'essentiel n'a pas bougé alors
justement c'est une question que
j'allais vous poser merci de me tendre
la perche est-ce que vous dites encore
une jolie bosse au milieu au centre ceux
qui sont nés à gauche ni à droite qui
sont également attirés par ce parti donc
pas extrême droite au sens des années 30
mais plus à droite que tous les autres
et un peu poussé à vif tout ce qui est
thème de droite c'est-à-dire c'est
difficile de différencier la gauche et
la droite
bobbiole le philosophe italien disait
c'est l'égalité qui caractérise la
gauche et la vision autoritaire
hiérarchique inégale qui caractérise la
droite et ce condensé inégalité
hiérarchie autorité elle est poussée au
maximum à l'incandescence par les
électeurs et par le parti de même
martial Foucault les électeurs justement
vous avez en partie répondu à la
question mais les électeurs actuels du
rassemblement national est-ce qu'il se
sente et ce qui se disent d'extrême
droite
je vais répondre dans dans poursuivant
ce que ce que disait à l'instant de la
meilleure oui non seulement les
électeurs en général savent positionner
le parti rassemblement national très
très très à droite et eux-mêmes s'auto
positionne très facilement très très
très à droite donc mais il y a une
époque par nos interrompre ou c'était
beaucoup moins assumé d'ailleurs les
instituts de sondages ont eu du mal à
évaluer les les scores du Front national
en partie à cause de ça oui alors c'est
pour une raison peut-être plus
méthodologique parce que c'est vrai que
quand vous devez répondre les yeux dans
les yeux à un enquêteur en face à face
pour dire j'assume mon vote dans les
années 80-90 pour le Front national de
l'époque c'est pas simple bien sûr le
téléphone a un petit peu arrangé les
choses et puis les enquêtes en ligne ont
peut-être sont tombés dans l'autre excès
ou cette fois-ci on peut
instrumentaliser son choix de vote pour
faire passer des messages mais
l'électorat pour revenir sur la question
de l'électorat ou du profil sociologique
de l'électorat du Front national il y a
une polémique depuis près de 20 ans où
on s'interroge je crois que la réponse
elle est évidente mais certains ne
veulent pas entendre cette réponse et la
question est-ce que le rassemblement
national est devenu le premier parti des
ouvriers c'est une question classique
pour dire voyez maintenant le
rassemblement national est capable de
s'adresser parce qu'il y aurait eu un
virage idéologique à une classe
populaire qui autrefois votée à gauche
mais c'est un peu ce que disait Marine
Le Pen Steve vient de le rappeler en
2012 quand elle arrive à la tête du
quand elle dit la vraie vie c'est nous
quoi c'est une façon de de s'adresser à
cette partie de la population c'est
beaucoup plus nuancé
il faut rappeler et toujours rappeler
que le premier vote le premier parti des
ouvriers c'est l'abstention et une fois
qu'on regarde les ouvriers qui décident
et ils sont peu nombreux moins de 35%
aux dernières élections présidentielles
à voter alors effectivement le
rassemblement national
et le premier choix de cet électorat
mais c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
que de dire c'est le premier parti des
ouvriers laissant entendre que tous les
ouvriers adhéreraient aux thèses du
rassemblement national puis une deuxième
dimension moi ce qui m'avait frappé dans
un travail qu'on avait mené il y a 5 ans
lors de l'élection présidentielle de
2017 il y avait une caractéristique pour
reprendre cette opposition extrême
gauche extrême droite ou gauche extrême
gauche droite extrême c'est qu'il y a un
élément qui oppose ces radicalité c'est
sur des questions plus subjectives c'est
le niveau de confiance vis-à-vis des
autres le rassemblement national est un
parti dont les électeurs n'ont pas
confiance dans les autres c'est à dire
que dans les interactions sociales dans
les sociabilités ce sont des électeurs
qui se méfient et pourquoi c'est
important parce qu'à partir du moment où
vous méfiez des autres comment
pouvez-vous accepter l'idée que les
politiques publiques qu'on vous propose
vous sont adressés et c'est toujours la
dialectique c'est ce n'est pas pour nous
c'est pour les autres et ça il y a un
ressort pour moi important qu'on a
peut-être pas encore suffisamment
travaillé qui est ce rapport à
l'altérité et on voit bien que du côté
de l'extrême gauche ou de la gauche
extrême on n'est pas du tout sur ces
niveaux de défiance interpersonnelle
alors je reviens cet anniversaire
embarrassant ou important on va choisir
les mots regardez ce qu'on dit quand
même Philippe Olivier qui est conseillé
de Marine Le Pen chargé justement de
l'organisation de l'événement c'était
dans Le Parisien la semaine dernière
cette citation donc au sujet de ce
colloque d'anniversaire va-t-on
instruire notre propre procès non on
n'est pas maso d'autres le feront pour
nous les dérapages de Le Pen on les a
déjà condamnés même sur l'Europe nous
avons un fléchi notre position alors il
a raison Laetitia puisque do il dit
d'autres se chargent bien sûr le procès
ben il fait évidemment le parti
Renaissance parti présidentielle a lancé
ce week-end à hashtag un modi # intitulé
50 ans de fnhaine oui c'est une
opération comme qui a démarré sur
Twitter et Facebook samedi à 20h30
précise avec une parodie d'invitation on
va voir l'infographie un petit carton
comme ça une invitation reçue dit
Renaissance avec le cachet de la poste
de montre tout monsieur Jean-Marie Le
Pen premier président du nationale et
Madame Marine Le Pen fondatrice du
rassemblement national vous invite à
célébrer hashtag 50 ans de FN comme vous
l'avez dit
haine sur Twitter chaque soir à 20h30
propose
exigé ça donne quoi ça donne une vidéo
d'archives qui est diffusée chaque soir
c'est ça oui il y en a déjà eu trois
alors on a vu par exemple un extrait
d'une conférence de presse ou Marine Le
Pen se prononçait pour le frexit pour
montrer qu'elle a complètement changé de
position il y a eu aussi une vidéo un
peu un zapping de moments où des
journalistes sont malmenés par les
services d'ordre ou par même les
rappelez-vous monsieur golniche avec son
parapluie qui tapait sur les reporters
de quotidien non du Petit Journal à
l'époque de Canal+ donc il y a eu ces
deux vidéos et puis j'ai retenu moi une
troisième vidéo c'est une archive qui
date de
1979 Simone Veil doit animer une réunion
publique sur l'Europe quand une clique
du Front national avec à l'intérieur de
cette clique genre Marine Le Pen vient
perturber le déroulement écoutez alors
la réponse de Simone Veil objectif c'est
de montrer la filiation entre le Front
national du Père et le rassemblement
national de la fille oui s'en cache pas
du tout vous savez que le nouveau patron
du parti présidentiel c'est Stéphane
séjourné un très proche du chef de
l'État qui a toujours lui vraiment
bataillé pour montrer cette filiation
idéologique entre le RN et le FN et donc
il a demandé à ses troupes de monter un
peu dans la riposte d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que certaines de ces
vidéos vont être aussi diffusées sur Tik
Tok justement vous avez raison pour
toucher un public jeune 15 20 ans qui ne
connaissent pas forcément
Jean-Marie Le Pen et donc bah alors
Stéphane séjourner et Aurore berger qui
est chargé à l'intérieur de renaissance
de la riposte ont mis carrément la main
la pâte c'est vraiment perché
apparemment qui aurait trouvé en tout va
peaufiner ce hashtag et elle en a fait
le service après-vente elle-même dans Le
Parisien dimanche elle dit ce qu'on
retient du rassemblement national c'est
qu'ils sont polis et qu'ils portent une
cravate nous ferons tomber les masques
alors la cravate c'est en référence vous
savez avec cette théorisé par par
certains casques du parti de la
stratégie de la cravate pour bien
montrer qu'on est maintenant notabilisé
alors quand j'ai discuté avec le
directeur de la communication de
renaissance donc ce parti présidentiel
il a dit que carrément il assumait
encore que le RN n'est pas pour lui un
parti comme les autres donc ce sera tout
le mois d'octobre tous les soirs à 20h30
une vidéo diffusée je vais un petit peu
spoiler ce soir on aura le Jean-Marie Le
Pen et le point de détails de l'histoire
de la deuxième guerre mondiale alors
effectivement le point de détail tiens
je vous propose je vous propose nos
archive qui est intéressante sur la
capacité qu'avait Jean-Marie le peine à
[Musique]
assumer ressortir plusieurs fois vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure cette cette
citation sur les chambres à gaz point de
détails de l'histoire l'archive qu'on a
choisi on est en 2009 il est devant le
Parlement européen il assume et il
répète sa phrase écouter je me suis
borné à dire que les chambres à gaz
c'est un détail de l'histoire de la
guerre mondiale
qui a été ce qui est ce qui est une
évidence ce qui est une évidence
[Applaudissements]
je rappelle que à cette occasion madame
le Président j'ai été condamné à 200 000
euros de dommages et intérêts
ce qui prouve ce qui prouve l'état dans
lequel se trouve la liberté d'opinion et
la liberté d'expression en Europe et en
France
mais écoutez vos cris ne masqueront pas
votre responsabilité dans la crise qui
est celle de l'euro mondialisme donc
vous êtes les partisans
donna Mayer qu'est-ce qui reste de cette
frange
antisémite nostalgie de l'Algérie
française je pourrais rajouter beaucoup
de de qualificatifs au sein du
rassemblement national il y en a qui
sont nostalgiques de l'Algérie et qui ne
sont pas antisémites
l'Algérie française je pense que pour la
nostalgie de l'Algérie française c'est
quelque chose qui ne touche concerne pas
du tout les nouvelles générations c'est
pas du tout leur histoire ça a été très
important dans la fondation du parti
quand on a vu les premiers militants
tous les travaux montrent dans toute la
région PACA provençal Côte d'Azur il y a
plein de travaux qui ont été faits
notamment sur la ville de Toulon on voit
très clairement le rôle qu'on jouait une
partie des pieds-noirs tous les
Pieds-Noirs n'ont pas soutenu le Front
national mais par nostalgie pour le pays
perdu par nostalgie pour l'Algérie
française quant à l'antisémitisme
on fait chaque année pour la Commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme un sondage pour le gouvernement
où nous avons le bilan de toutes les
formes de racisme et de préjugés et on a
des questions plein de questions sur
l'antisémitisme chaque année depuis 1990
ce qui reste les plus antisémites ce
sont ceux qui se déclarent proches du
Front national donc Marine Le Pen peut
avoir dit avec Louis Aliot que c'est une
ligne rouge à ne pas franchir ça n'a pas
totalement changé au sein du parti même
si l'antisémitisme y est moins fort
comparé au rejet de l'islam et des
musulmans qui est beaucoup plus marqué
aujourd'hui mais l'antisémitisme reste
beaucoup plus fort chez les électeurs et
les sympathisants du Front national que
dans n'importe quel autre électorat j'ai
une petite question pour Abel Mestre
justement parce que pendant la campagne
elle a laissé échapper une phrase Marine
Le Pen sur l'islam qui n'était pas un
problème pour la République c'est
engageant de dire ça quand on est
responsable d'un parti qui stigmatise
les musulmans alors
[Musique]
pour faire contraste par rapport à
Zemmour elle voyait bien que et Marine
Le Pen à chaque fois qu'elle est face à
un plus radical qu'elle a toujours la
même stratégie c'est qu'elle laisse
s'échapper comme au vélo elle laisse le
plus radical s'échapper puis elle reste
elle elle surgeout la modération pour
montrer que par contrat ça les
fréquentable je pense que c'est une
stratégie d'ailleurs les hémoriens les
humoristes je sais pas comment on dit
les hémoriens lui ont reproché même une
photo un selfie qu'elle avait fait avec
une jeune femme voilée elle aura répondu
mais qu'est-ce que vous vouliez que que
je lui enlève le voile comme en
référence à ce que l'effet Zemmour dans
une émission de télévision voilà donc
c'était aussi un jeu de contraste en
disant voilà je suis plus fréquentable
vous voyez je suis je suis pas aussi
radical car il est mort moi je l'avais
analysé comme ça martial Foucault on
analyse et je reviens à cette date de de
2012 donc l'arrivée de Marine Le Pen à
la tête du Front national encore à
l'époque si on analyse la décennie
écoulée c'est le mouvement Front
National accurationnel qui concentrer ou
c'est la société française qui s'est
droitisé
c'est très compliqué de répondre à cette
question est-ce que la société française
c'est droitisée parce que c'est pas un
tout homogène il y a des dimensions sur
lesquelles oui sur un certain nombre de
questions
culturelles on peut observer une
droiteisation sur des questions
économiques vous voyez le terme
droitisation d'ailleurs il n'est pas
toujours adapté est-ce qu'il y a une
ouverture plus libérale ou plus
conservateur moi ce que j'observe c'est
si on rapporte cela à l'électorat
aujourd'hui du rassemblement national
les adhérents du rassemblement national
ne sont pas je dirais au diapason des
idées du Front national de l'époque donc
il y a une grande évolution sur ces
questions et pour preuve on voit bien
qu'un certain nombre de d'électeurs
j'irai de moins de 40 ans ont adhéré au
test de Marine Le Pen non pas sur des
grandes questions idéologiques mais
avant tout sur la foi un rejet des
partis traditionnels ça c'est un premier
élément cette idée qui a été bien
cultivée par Marine Le Pen je crois
contrairement à son père et que l'on
peut voir aujourd'hui autour des leaders
européens d'extrême droite cette
opposition entre le peuple et les élites
alors ça je pense que vraiment la marque
de Marine Le Pen c'est d'avoir réussi à
incarner cette opposition et à faire
vivre cette opposition populiste puisque
peuple contre les élites et puis une
troisième une troisième dimension qui me
semble intéressante c'est sa conversion
sur le plan économique je pense que
c'est un élément de l'élargissement de
son électorat devenant la défenseuse des
services publics
défonceuse des classes les plus
défavorisées aux revenus modestes et ça
c'est un tournant qui a conduit un
certain nombre d'électeurs peut-être
déçus d'une gauche qui ne représentait
plus les intérêts de ces catégories
sociales de se dire non pas seulement
après tout pourquoi ne pas essayer le
rassemblement national mais ça a été
pour en tout cas pour des électeurs qui
souhaitaient toujours participer et
exercer leur droit civique de se dire
cette candidate finalement on retient
ses positions économiques sociales
plutôt que
doctrine sa colonne vertébrale comme
disait elmestre autour de la préférence
nationale moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est en
2017 j'ai souvenir dans un travail qui
avait été mené d'observer que
l'électorat considérait que Marine Le
Pen était la candidate qui représentait
le mieux la candidate la plus crédible
sur les questions sociales en 2017 et
pour moi ça c'est un élément de la
transformation idéologique très profonde
par rapport à ce que son père n'aurait
jamais osé incarner et mettre en avant
dans une campagne puisqu'on compare en
fait à la fois le Père la fille aussi
l'évolution de l'électorat de ce
mouvement
les électorat de Jean-Marie Le Pen était
quand même assez majoritairement
masculin ou en tout cas il y avait une
part d'hommes plus importante ça s'est
rééquilibré aujourd'hui
là peut-être la différence fondamentale
entre ces deux électorats qui pour le
reste ont des grosses structures
comparables c'est-à-dire c'est le niveau
de diplôme qui joue le niveau
d'insécurité économique le fait qu'ils
ont tous les deux le père et fille
attirer des électeurs dans les
catégories les plus populaires qui
votaient à droite les petits commerçants
artisans puis dans les catégories les
plus populaires qui votaient à gauche
c'est à dire les ouvriers mais ce qui
est fait la différence entre le père et
la fille c'est que lui il répulsait les
femmes on avait jusqu'à dans certaines
élections 7 points d'écart entre le
niveau moyen de soutien des hommes et
des femmes à cause du père parce qu'il
avait des propos sexistes misogynes et
parce qu'il avait aussi une aura de
violence et d'extrémisme et cette
fameuse stratégie de dédiabolisation de
Marine Le Pen elle a marché auprès des
femmes parce que beaucoup de femmes
avaient été tout à fait d'accord avec
les idées du Front national du temps du
père il y avait trop d'immigrés en
France elles avaient peur de l'Islam ils
avaient peur marcher seul dans la rue
c'était la faute des étrangers mais elle
ne passait pas le pas parce que
Jean-Marie Le Pen faisait obstacle et
Marine Le Pen elle a provoqué le déclic
et il y a ses frais à travers toute
l'Europe c'est ce qu'on appelle le
radical Wright John de Gap le un gap
différentiel sur le vote pour les droits
local populiste dans la majorité des
pays européens il existe encore en
France Marine Le Pen l'a fait
disparaître aux élections
présidentielles en 2012 en 2017 et en
2022 et même en 2017 les jeunes femmes
ont voté plus souvent pour elle au
premier tour un tiers que les jeunes
hommes du même âge incarnent autrement
dit elle a réussi quelque chose elle a
réussi parce que pourquoi si j'ai le
temps de dire deux mots pourquoi est-ce
que les femmes étaient plus réticentes
il y a une masse de travaux là-dessus il
y avait l'idée que elles étaient moins
exposées au chômage après karité à la
mondialisation que les hommes c'était
les ouvriers catégories principalement
masculines elles étaient plutôt dans des
boulots non manuels et plus protégés
c'est plus vrai on a aujourd'hui une
précarisation des femmes une montée d'un
prolétariat de service féminin et ce
sont ces femmes là qui sont mises à
voter pour Marine Le Pen le deuxième
facteur c'était la religion les femmes
âgées plus pratiquantes plus attachées
aux valeurs des évangiles et en France
les évêques à plusieurs reprises avec
retourner le FN mais justement avec la
plus grande visibilité de l'espace de
l'islam dans l'espace public se rempart
du catholicisme a commencé à s'effriter
un petit peu et puis il y avait le
féminisme pour les jeunes femmes je dis
on allait quand même pas voter pour un
Jean-Marie Le Pen pour qu'il la place
des femmes c'était au foyer faire des
enfants mais la dernière chose et c'est
là que la stratégie des diabolisation à
jouer malgré l'émancipation des femmes
on continue à élever autrement les
petits garçons et les petites filles ont
les petites filles on ne leur conseille
d'être obéissante soumise plus conformes
tandis que les garçons ont favorise
l'affirmation de soi même l'agressivité
et c'est ce qui les détourne à travers
toute l'Europe de partie extrême violent
hors norme Marine Le Pen a changé la
donne et c'est là c'est une révolution
un peu invisible mais aujourd'hui les
femmes sont majoritaires dans son
électorat alors qu'avant elles étaient
minoritaires personnelles aussi a servi
à changer à donne elle est séparée elle
est divorcée elle parle de ses enfants
elle est en couple
elle est en col absolument enfin je veux
dire elle a une vie ultra moderne dans
laquelle peuvent se retrouver pour même
les a ciblés là-dessus elle a fait des
quatre pages spécifiquement dégénéré
fait pour les femmes en disant je suis
une femme une Française une mère une
travailleuse une femme moderne ça nous
rappelle Mélanie nous c'est plutôt John
Mélanie
l'idée à Marine Le Pen un mot vous
l'avez évoqué rapidement des des députés
rassemblements national à l'Assemblée 89
députés effectivement il y a cette
stratégie de quoi de laisser la
provocation
à LFI et à ses alliés de la de la nu
vous diriez que ça fonctionne pour
l'instant
priori en tout cas c'est perçu comme une
opposition qui est plus raisonnable et
plus acceptée par par les Français et en
tout cas c'est surtout la manière de
s'opposer de la France insoumise qui est
qui est rejeté par une majorité de
Français après ça continue dans la
stratégie de diabolisation aussi de
d'institutionnalisation du du Front
national du rassemblement national
pardon ou en gros Marine Le Pen elle
veut à la fois ne pas être dans le
système mais dans les institutions et
donc du coup c'est encore une fois une
ligne de crête très compliquée à tenir
mais
elle veut à la fois s'opposer au
gouvernement en disant on votera
l'émotion de censure de la gauche si
force sur les retraites mais en même
temps quand elle prend la parole à
l'Assemblée nationale elle a dit on sera
dans une opposition raisonnable et s'il
y a des s'il y a des points qui font
avancer les choses qui vont dans nos
sens on les votera on fera pas une
opposition systématique et donc c'est
vrai que c'est ce
voilà ce cette mesure qui qui est plutôt
appréciée et qui est en fait
arrive à placer le RN comme une
opposition crédible et elle son objectif
c'est de dire voilà moi je veux que les
Français se projettent
avec un gouvernement du RN avec des
députés qui peuvent être émises pas
forcément une président de la République
mais aussi des ministres de la de la
justice de l'intérieur on est capable de
d'exercer le pouvoir massage vous
convient avec avec vous le CI pop publie
ce mardi sont son étude annuelle sur les
fractures françaises ils étaient avec le
monde la Fondation Jean Jaurès
soprastaia et Ipsos alors on peut c'est
ultra vaste mais sur la question je te
demande des des députés du du
rassemblement national comment ils sont
perçus par par les Français je disais
une étude à risque interactive aussi qui
qui dit quasiment c'est les plus
convaincants en tout cas dans de plus
dans le début de de ce second
quinquennat de je vais pas commenter
l'enquêtarisme mais sur sur l'enquête
avec Yves saut c'est le monde et
Fondation Jean Jaurès effectivement
souvent ce que d'Isabelle baisse serait
juste c'est à dire que la perception
qu'on les Français c'est une opposition
qui est arrivée au pouvoir un peu par
surprise par le nombre de députés et que
il renvoie une image de députés qui ont
peut-être aujourd'hui plus vite compris
les codes
parlementaires et je crois qu'il y a une
vraie culture parlementaire qui va
prendre plusieurs mois pour s'installer
au sein des députés rassemblants
national mais en fait on a souvent
condamné au Parlement les comportements
godillots des députés qui votaient au
nom du chef du groupe là finalement on a
en termes d'attitude des députés aussi
très godillaux sur un autre registre moi
je pense que cette stratégie de
normalisation peut atteindre aussi ses
limites parce que ce parti a réussi ce
coup électoral précisément en jouant le
comme je disais tout à l'heure
l'opposition entre les autres parties et
nous qui sommes différents à partir du
moment où ce normalisent on ne sait pas
véritablement où se place le curseur qui
dans les cinq prochaines années
parviendra à dépasser je reprends la
métaphore du vélo mais à dépasser
l'échapper de cette radicalité en étant
encore plus radical et faisant du parti
rassemblement national un parti normal
très normal peut-être même trop normal
pour continuer à engranger effectivement
un soutien des électeurs merci beaucoup
merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vous dis à
bientôt sur sur Public Sénat voilà c'est
la fin de cette émission merci à toutes
et à tous de votre fidélité je vous
donne rendez-vous demain 18h 22h et puis
ne ratez pas dans la matinale Oriane
mansini reçoit François Patriat le
président du groupe rassemblement des
démocrates progressistes et indépendant
Renaissance au Sénat belle soirée à
toutes et à tous
[Musique]